was that Debbie I help you yes I'm
calling for John and John's about 84 he
has dementia how bad it's just starting
pretty bad I mean he goes for walks and
don't remember where he is and well I
mean he's new on his own in his own
house and I want to keep him there and I
don't know what you could prescribe sure
okay what is he wait what is John way
John is a small man I'd say he's about
maybe five three and he's sin and he's a
complete vegan
okay so caring maybe a hundred hundred
pounds there's maybe a hundred can close
enough close enough does he have any
other issues you know any medication for
diabetes or high blood pressure heart
disease or anything like that no nothing
he's totally like clean of that stuff he
uses filtered water he uses vegan stuff
like on to eat grapes
maybe your is it should I tell me any
kind of wine I told the eggs you know I
didn't really know diet is there any way
you can ask you what to eat you
well let's start out by giving you the
information okay as we want to eat up a
lot of time with somebody who's you know
swollen responding this sort of stuff so
it's better that you can and make sure
he gets information let's start there
okay sure Maine
yes okay again happy anniversary oh
thank you okay my son my son Mike and
Walter and I are all right out back
because we picked up some furniture for
Center breakfast lower seating and we're
headed for home okay cool again happy
anniversary okay now what we do for
Debbie's friend John 84 years old he
weighs 110 pounds and he's got dementia
of course there's five different
dimensions major ones and what we could
give to support healthy brain function
in the case of all five of those
dimensions what I would give him and for
those issues is a healthy brain and
heart pack and then I will
after that the ultimate daily classic
the niacin plus the synapses and the
a DD what is s now Sharma is quite
correct
at 110 pounds John should be taking one
healthy brain and heart panic Vermont
but also have him take the D stress
capsules okay these shows councils
cattle D like David - dress take three
of those 20 sedate and then I would also
haven't taken the ultimate daily classic
tablets three of those twice a is to buy
us a month and that's particularly to
support healthy blood flows through
blocked arteries in the brain bastard
dimension and the the let's see here but
move of a that is going to cover all the
dimensions except how many days do you
think John should have Charmaine
probably about six today yeah six days
poached selfie Oh soft-boiled soft yolk
soft cell scrambling butter and that's
going to provide the cholesterol
necessary to help the brain repair
itself
the brain of all vertebrates including
humans is 75% white matter and the
myelin the insulation Charlemagne and
this white matter is composed of 95% or
more almost 100 sets cholesterol and so
many people get put on statin drugs
because it has you know cholesterol
issues or our triglyceride issues
doctors will put them on eight beaters
and margins that are butter and
non-dairy coffee creamers and low-fat
yogurt and zero fat milk and all kind of
stuff really need to eat more fat and
remember you need to listen to that CD
and he needs listen the CD a stick of
butter day keeps doctor way